for the bull train you have a say in
French cheese that does not smell cannot
be anonymous cheese we like to eat
cheese with one and just we eat it for
the cheese with other days you eat it
with something out yeah with crackers
practic in France you just choose just a
piece of cheese like this and not with
crackers yeah nothing nice to say
looking forward to trying this but let's
see it's just one color yeah it's just
there's no like little things in it
otherwise or nothing a very example it's
not bad way it's what we call in France
the cheese the [ __ ] it tastes like
cheese for one second mmm and then it
does not it has a bit of bitterness to
it but very very light just a little bit
smoked tasty okey it's like the cream
you put the coffee like half and half
oh my serves like mayo
the texture is very sandy and dry how
does it they taste like those little
cheese puffs that you can buy it man has
cheese sauce with a bit of light orange
colouring it's like a mixture between
salty and sweet and women but at the
same time it's neither and really like
acidic you're in a rush to get your food
you're going to get fruit that tastes
like it has been made in Russia and it's
it doesn't have to taste bad but won't
taste as good as it could be
you should eat food because you enjoy it
you enjoy the taste of it you shouldn't
just eat it to fill yourself and a lot
of this American cheese in general feels
just like to fill yourself up but to put
on a burger and just kind any doesn't
taste it isn't it
it's not good for your body and it
wasn't good for your desire to eat
something good
you